what are some quick tips for making a
great impression on video okay number
one is the distance between your nose
and the camera so you should measure the
distance between your nose and the
camera and you should try to be a foot
and a half to three feet away very
specifically the reason for that is
because in human behavior research
researchers have found that there is
this called proxemic the study of space
there are four zones for people and the
public zone is the Zone that's farthest
away then we get to the social Zone this
is about five to seven feet away then we
get to the personal Zone this is where
we have most of our onetoone
conversations where we feel comfortable
at in a coffee shop or talking to
someone in the break room or on a date
and the last zone is called the intimate
Zone that's about 18 0 to 18 inches away
this is
preissing this is pre- Doctor exam pre-
dental exam the mistake that a lot of
people make on camera is they get too
close to their camera and it triggers
invasive cues we don't even realize it's
happening but if I were to give my
entire do my entire videos really close
to the camera it would immediately be
like whoa back up now there is a caveat
to this which is if you have a really
intimate Channel you want to be zero to
18 inches away so for me my My Demo is
brilliantly smart professionals so I
know that they don't want to get
intimate with me nor do I want to get
intimate with them right I'm married
right it's not a dating channel so I
send a Quee right from the first start
of zero to of 18 to 3 feet away if
you're doing a dating Channel if you are
doing makeup tutorials you might
consider hitting that 0 to8 inches an
example of this is um limit list the
documentary on I think it's Netflix with
um uh Hemsworth have you seen that
documentary I've seen that documentary
very cool okay so they shot him zero to
18 inches away if you look at him doing
his interviews it's so close to his face
I went ah human behavior Q they are
signaling me with the content we're
going to get personal we're we're going
to get deep Hemsworth is going to share
so think about space in terms of how you
want to be intimate with your audience
so powerful and you shared tip number
one just give us tip number two for
making a great impression on video hands
so hand gestures from a biological
perspective we love to see gestures and
what happens on video is we forget about
our G gestures we're thinking a lot
about our content our delivery our face
maybe our hair right what we forget
about is our gestures so research finds
that we put a lot of mental focus onto
gestures so for example right now I'm
speaking with my hands if I were to say
I have a really big idea but I were to
hold my fingers up really small your
brain is more likely to believe my
gesture over my over my my words if I
were to say today I want to talk to you
about five big ideas but hold up the
number three your brain is more likely
to believe my gesture and that is
because it's really that was so hard to
do by the way like just try right now
just say five but hold up three ready
five five five it's horrible right does
your brain hurt yeah so the reason for
that is because our brain really likes
to be congruent with our gestures so the
when as viewers they know that highly
competent people know their content so
well they can speak to you on two tracks
they can speak to you with their words
but they can also speak to you with your
with their with their gestures or their
hands so a really good speaker
especially a captivating um video
creator they're saying hey everyone they
show their hand usually with some sort
of you know wave or greeting which I do
every time we see a palm we immediately
relax and they're often demoing their
concepts with their words which
increases retention and also increases
memorability so people are more likely
to remember three points points hold up
three fing well you're already tapping
into this powerful idea of cu's you're
the author of Q's Master The Secret
Language of charismatic communication
tell us what even is a q oh yes so a q
is a subtle but powerful social signal
now we are sending thousands of these
social signals every video they come in
four channels and we often don't realize
we have four ways to communicate our
cues the first one is the most obvious
our words our verbal communication and
that's not just how clear we are it's
also words we use to cue Behavior so we
are always on the lookout for Behavioral
cues second is our voice so how we say
our words our volume our Pace our
Cadence third is our body language or
non-verbal our facial gestures our hand
gestures our posture our movement in
space and the last one is our ornaments
that's the colors we wear in our YouTube
videos what's behind us and our YouTube
videos any props we have The Branding
fonts colors we use and our animations
or our captions those are four
opportunities that you have to influence
how someone behaves or how they feel
connected to you and how did cues come
about uh what was the origin story of
you starting to observe these things and
collect these cues yes so I'm a
recovering awkward person my YouTube
channel is all about being awkward and
having to learn social skills from
scratch I'm not a natural extrovert I'm
not naturally good with people and so um
I did not understand cues I felt like I
had missed the memo on how you to
interact with people how to make
conversation um what to do with your
hands how to stand how to read faces and
so it actually started as a personal
project of mine where I wanted to
catalog literally create like a like a
dictionary or Encyclopedia of cues for
myself and as I was doing this spent
number of years doing this in the
beginning part of my career I realized
that a there were patterns B there was
research there was really interesting
research on these cues Universal cues
there are some cultural cues of course
but there's Universal ones and I created
these 96 cues in these four different
channels and I thought you know maybe I
should share some of these cues so I
started to share some on my YouTube
channel just like to test the waters
YouTube is amazing I I'm so grateful to
YouTube because it is the it was the
Tipping Point in my career like my
career started on YouTube not my blog so
YouTube is so amazing because it allows
you to test content to see how it will
do so I just started slowly analyzing
cues on YouTube and I started YouTube in
2007 so I've been on YouTube for a long
time and I've been doing a video a week
since 2007 talk about a Content
treadmill that's it's a whole different
issue I started I did a video you know
analyzing the Rocks Alpha cues
just for fun just to like see what would
happen like breaking down how the rock
is the rock um I did one on Britney
Spears deception cues and obviously they
did very very well on YouTube and I went
okay there's something here and that's
when I pitched it was my second book I
pitched that to my um publisher and it
turned out to be more successful than I
ever could have imagined so yeah what
are like two or three of the most
powerful cues that would make an
immediate impact on viewer retention on
YouTube and improve Ming our content
online I'm going to give really small
ones I think they're the ones that are
overlooked I like to think of Q's like a
golf swing right like a golf swing you
can hit the ball but if you want to get
the ball to the right place there are
these micro adjustments in your stance
in your hands it's the same thing with
cues we know the obvious ones right like
make eye contact we know that QE right
smile if you feel happy we know that one
like those are cues those are great um
but I like the small ones that I think
differentiate a good Creator from a
great Creator so one of my favorites is
the lean so remember how I mentioned the
four zones of space so as I began to
study these cues I watched thousands of
hours of TED Talks my team and I
actually coded every single Ted Talk
that was posted from 2010 looking for
patterns I wanted to know what were the
differences between the most viewed TED
talks and the least viewed TED talks
like I you know if you watch Ted these
are all successful smart people why is
it that some videos get millions of
views and some get thousands of views so
we catalog these videos I thank my
research team thank you research team we
cataloged every single queue we could
find we clocked a number of smiling we
looked at stage presence we looked at
gestures one of the big things that we
found was that the really good speakers
they use space to their advantage and
they would use leans when they really
wanted you to pay attention so they were
literally crossing the space zone so in
my videos often when I'm sharing
something that I think is really
important or I really want to emphasize
it I'll literally lean into the camera
like this this is it and I think it
wakes people up like it immediately
makes people like oh she's leaning in I
better get it it's very subtle it's a
couple of inches in fact one research
study studi lean so if you want to do a
little experiment with me so wherever
you are right now just lean forward
three inches just give it a
second they found that just doing that
activates a certain part of your
prefrontal cortex that is
pre-action so when I move in it actually
gives me energy so it imbus my words a
little bit more energy it makes me look
like I'm telling you something really
good but also sometimes listeners
viewers will lean into to the video like
literally they hear they see the lean
they lean themselves and that's makes
them more likely to like more likely to
subscribe they're literally pre-action
you're activating that prefrontal cortex
and I think and I've looked at my
analytics on this when I lean in a video
I get more engagement on the video I get
more replays on that section like are
like the most replayed parts of my
videos and I get more engagement so I I
think that there's something to that so
alen is a small one but it's so powerful
what if you learned you're a very
prolific content creator I was also
originally I think our mutual friend
Rory Vaden was talking about you I saw
your powerful presence as an author and
in a world of as you said kind of a
little bit of the corporate world you
know smart people speaking all this
different things but one of the rare
things I observed was you're on way to
900,000 subscribers and I think that
YouTube is one of the biggest missed
opportunities by a lot of women
entrepreneurs by a lot of entrepreneurs
in general um and sometimes they're more
active on other platforms you're like a
YouTube Legend you've been on the
platform since 2007 yeah um break down
some of the lessons that you've learned
after posting
570 videos to your channel oh wow yes so
many okay first big lesson was
I went from casual to formal to
somewhere in between and I share that
because I think there's a Temptation for
creators to script or to overly practice
or to overly rehearse before a video and
there's a very fine line between
prepping for a video knowing your
content getting in getting out being
tight and being overly rehearsed or
overly formal so when I first started on
YouTube 2007 so just to paint the
landscape for anyone who was remembered
that time YouTube was like this new Wild
West no one knew what it was it was
pretty much just unboxing videos like
that that's really all it was very few
people were teaching on there and so in
the very beginning it was very informal
I was doing it like with a very casual
camera no lighting I did a couple out
like in a restaurant oh my gosh you know
very very casual then YouTube got real
serious people were like oh YouTube is a
thing and that's when there was a time
between 2009 to like 2014 or 15 where it
was like professional lighting makeup
amazing backgrounds amazing Studios and
so people were investing a ton in their
technology and that's when I got really
tight that's also when I got to film at
YouTube studios in LA and it got I my
video started decline actually at that
point like I was getting a lot of views
at first and then I realized I was like
pumping out these videos on a beautiful
set 4K you know cameras and perfect
perfect teleprompter scripts and I
started to lose engagement started to
lose those views and I think what was
happening then is it felt robotic and so
I beg you do not use a
teleprompter please please do not use a
teleprompter I know it feels safe I know
it feels comfortable I know you want to
keep it tight and deliver the best
content you can but it kills Charisma
like it is almost impossible to read a
teleprompter script as a human it
doesn't matter how charismatic you are
and so I had to wean myself off
teleprompters because we were watching
my analytics and I was like like my they
don't do as well so now I'm back to no
teleprompter and I I don't have one in
my studio because it's too tempting when
it's on uh bullets and prep but I think
the big lesson I learned was like real
you have to act like you're hopping into
a conversation with a friend powerful
and break down your workflow today is it
do you come up with your content alone
are you thoughtful about this is what my
title is going to be I'm going to craft
that this is what the text in the
thumbnail is going to be what is your
current workflow as you're coming up
with video ideas okay so I for about 10
years I was a one-woman show edited all
my own videos and all my own Graphics
that was very very hard if you're if
you're a one man or one woman show I I
give you so much strength and credit and
like I'm sending you so much energy
because it is so hard and I I get it
I've been there you're doing a great job
like that's what I want to say if you're
if you're doing it on your own now I
have a team so that I'll break down my
workflow so I am very purposeful with
every aspect of my videos because we
make a little bit of money on ad Revenue
but actually we've turned off ads on a
lot of our videos because they sell so
many books and so many of my courses so
I'm I know exactly who I'm reaching so
my viewer on YouTube and this is both
based on analytics as well as just who
we know is watching are high achieving
professionals that want to level up
their skills and they're usually very
talented very smart but they need a
little help on the awkwardness
confidence side so I know who they are
um and typically the very first thing we
do is we start with keyword research so
I have a team member shout out to Rob
Rob does keyword research for me at the
beginning of every month where he is
sitting in ah refs that's the tool that
we use and he is looking for topics that
our people are searching so this is
everything from confidence at work to
introverts at work to talking to my boss
to dealing with difficult people at work
to ice breakers and meeting
all those topics he's looking for for
opportunities we specifically look for
medium volume but not a lot of
competition I don't even try on the big
traffic ones they're too hard and medium
volume is it that's like my people so um
like an example would be tips for
introverts at work right that that's a
really specific title so we take those
keywords um he does research in both
Google and YouTube and that is because
YouTube is a search engine you should
only think of it as a search engine um
and so uh we look at can see what are
the keywords also what are the longtail
keywords this is kind of a little secret
hack which I think has really helped us
is because of AI our keyword um patterns
are changing from now from up until this
point people use short phrases they type
into YouTube or Google tips for
introverts introverts at work but what's
happening with AI is more and more
people are using an AI tool to search
the web and so they're going to type in
a much longer response so it might be
tips for introverts working in an open
Office Space it might be tips for
introverts talking to their boss and
colleagues at work tips for introverts
making friends at work so now we're
taking all the longtail keywords and
those are my chapters so I have my main
video and then I have chapters broken in
there so I get all that keyword research
from my uh Team Member Rob and then I
start to bullet point also um I have a
team member a couple writers who help me
with research so looking in the academic
databases what research is there I'm
noticed that differentiates my videos
from just random tips is if I can say
one research study from 2011 found that
84% of people are introverts at work
whatever it is um those are great for
social Clips because we make shorts out
of our long videos so I have my team
look for research Clips on the topic
then I bullet point you know I begin to
uh I don't script but begin to write out
kind of the structure of the video uh
then I film I do not spend too much time
writing and practicing I try to do it a
little bit more casual a little bit more
informal then it goes to my team member
Carolyn and she edits it for me um edits
the video she also pulls out two or
three shorts from the video sometimes we
wait on shorts to see what are the most
replayed parts of the video and then we
only use those as shorts then she
creates thumbnails for us using canva we
also then do really heavy keyword
descriptions to make sure that the
description is really uh keyword
friendly and then so it's a very it's a
very long answer I don't know if you
wanted this long answer um then uh it
goes into then we have an article arle
that gets created so one of our writers
uh creates an article from my video but
makes it way longer my sweet spot for
videos at the moment in this changes
based on the year on YouTube uh is about
four to 14 minutes something in there I
remember I'm not going for ad Revenue so
I am not doing it based on the ad
interstitials I'm doing it purely based
on content get in get out and most of my
professionals have a 10 to 20 minute
lunch that's what I'm going for or their
commute um so then they turn into an
article articles are usually five to 10
thousand words typically so they're
they're really beasts like they're long
and then we embed the video on the top
of the article and then I send it out to
my newsletter we have about 500,000
people on our newsletter which drives a
lot of of those early clicks that
usually happens with in the first 24
hours then the video often goes to all
of our socials and that is it that was
such a tactical answer a lot of value
there and one of the things that you
were also mentioning which was a
powerful YouTube Secret secret for
social media across the board but also
YouTube videos was being warm in your
content can you break that down yes so
um remember how I talked about scripting
is the death of Charisma I think that
there's a couple ways you can add warmth
to your videos so one take a step back
is Princeton University found that we
are very quickly judging people on two
traits warmth and competence those are
the two most important traits in all of
our communication this is especially
important on video when someone turns on
a video they are very quickly trying to
answer two questions about you can I
trust you can I rely on you so can I
trust that you're who you say you are
can I rely on you to give me good
information that's what they're trying
to answer within the first couple
seconds of your video right that's what
they're trying to answer I think that a
lot of creators go for competence I
certainly did right like in those formal
years I was like hit him with the
science right like tip tip tip and my
videos were very robotic if you look at
videos from that time period you can see
on my YouTube channel where I'm like 77%
of leaders need to be more confident
with their voice here are the five ways
that you can like it was extremely
helpful but not relatable at all I was
missing warmth so how does warmth look
on video so there there are specific
cues for warmth um one is movement and
expressive it's
expressiveness so when someone is being
all about the competence they're
delivering like this delivering with
their voice delivering with their
gestures there's very little facial
movement there's very little movement in
their in their in their frame most of my
thumbnails show some kind of movement
like typically that's where I add warmth
so it's me waving it's me leaning in
it's me making a silly face and my
videos are very competent so it's not
like I'm doing something silly but
movement is a way of showing warmth in
video it shows that you're not being too
scripted you're not being too formal so
movement facial expressiveness um
especially in your first 10 seconds so
like for example um I was just doing
this yesterday when I was filming I was
teaching on uh how to introduce yourself
so we have a video coming up a keyw that
we identified is how to introduce
yourself where people are nervous
introducing themselves they think it's
boring they don't know how to do it an
interesting way so the video is how to
introduce yourself the first intro I
recorded was like this ever struggle
with how to introduce yourself I'm going
to give you five quick ways and a
formula for how you can introduce
yourself to anyone it looked so boring
when I watched it back I was like oh my
my God like the the verbal was good but
I did not have enough expressiveness so
instead I recorded it something like
this where I added in the actual
awkwardness I feel in that situation so
it would be like have you ever had that
really awkward situation where you have
to introduce yourself but you don't know
how that facial expressiveness is
literally the feeling that I feel when I
have to introduce myself and it
immediately added warmth to the video so
it's not just smiling it's any kind of
facial expressiveness if you enjoyed
this content and want to take your
YouTube channel to the next level just
click or tap the link on the screen or
go to tube 1K challenge.com to join our
next live YouTube challenge you'll learn
our best tips and strategies that are
working here at think media and I think
you'll love it